Ціни на зріджений газ в Україні стрімко зросли.
За останні кілька тижнів - мало не вдвічі.
Існує кілька версій, чому традиційно
найдешевше для автомобілістів пальне раптом
різко подорожчало.
У Міністерстві економічного розвитку та торгівлі
головною причиною подорожчання автогазу
називають його дефіцит.
Українські виробники покривають лише двадцять відсотків
від потреб ринку.
Решту Україна імпортує - з Росії, Білорусі, Казахстану.
Додатково виникненню дефіциту сприяв ще й плановий ремонт на заводах
у Росії та Білорусі, звідки постачався автогаз.
А трейдери виявилися непідготовленими
й не запаслися вчасно цим пальним.
Через значно дешевші ціни на автогаз у порівнянні з бензином
попит на це пальне останнім роками
суттєво зріс.
За підрахунками експертів, кожен третій проданий в Україні літр пального
минулоріч був зрідженим газом. Трейдери, звісно ж,
не могли не помітити цієї тенденції і не нехтують можливістю
отримати більший зиск на попиті.
Ще одна версія - ціни на зріджений газ пішли вгору
через штучну монополізацію ринку.
Якщо раніше з Росії до України пропан-бутан постачали
6-7 виробників, то з травня цього року
таке право залишилося лише за однією компанією -
"Роснафтою". І продавати зріджений газ
вона може лише одному-єдиному
українському покупцеві -
трейдинговій компанії Proton Energy, яку оглядачі пов’язують
з кумом Володимира Путіна Віктором Медведчуком.
Більше того, як стверджує опозиційний депутат Сергій Лещенко,
збільшенню частки Proton Energy
на українському ринку до сорока відсотків
сприяла сама СБУ. Мовляв,
відбулося це таким чином: Служба Безпеки вимагала накласти
санкції на трейдерів зрідженого газу
наприкінці 2016-го -
на початку 2017-го років.
Це призвело до того,
що на три з половиною місяці було заблоковано роботу цього бізнесу,
імпортери зазнали значних збитків.
"Змовою" і диверсією проти України назвав подорожчання автогазу
й сам прем'єр Володимир Гройсман.
Він доручив профільним відомствам з'ясувати
причини й покарати винних. Вельми дивною
у цій історії видається поведінка Антимонопольного комітету.
Торік через подорожчання автогазу
лише на одну гривню АМКУ
негайно почала розслідування щодо можливої змови на ринку.
Цього ж разу навіть після подорожчання на 5 гривень
антимонопольники довго мовчали.
І заворушилися лише після того,
коли до них звернувся особисто прем'єр-міністр.